and
okay so the players just getting ready
napoli actually one e4
that would be my guess
you think so he's played a few things so
far this tournament he's played the
english
he's played e4
has he played d4 i can't quite remember
and it seems like it stays that way but
i have the feeling that now maybe it's
going to be a new trend that when people
are making their first move
they keep it that way for a moment
and then they take it back and they make
something new this is what happened
yesterday it was madness right that's
true
so i went there let me see the move goes
back
you see
okay is he teasing us though will he
play e4 anyway
like you know chess players are somehow
always go into the details and of course
these two guys there they have their
and okay e4 of course okay so no tricks
but
e4 on the board
and these guys they know each other
extremely extremely well the family
actually has acted as a second four
magnus in the past as well so there
won't be any opening surprises